[Music]
a new segment we have here called
photo friday home tour now last week we
showed a rather imperfect or it was two
weeks ago because with matt nathanson we
had the we had to skip this segment we
ran way over with him as we're running
over with jamie right now oh yeah that's
for you matt so what i'll tell you is
god i love him so much i can't wait to
listen to that podcast we had this
imperfect photo of my living room we're
just moving in and there's like tape on
the floor and there's like other things
going on in the living room and it's
rather incomplete what we're trying to
show is that minimalism doesn't have to
look like it always exists in a magazine
however today i'm going to show you my
level of ocd and you you're welcome to
criticize me here
this is my junk drawer danny unknown if
you want to pull up my junk drawer
this is literally my junk drawer i
changed only one thing to make it more
photogenic the
tape that you see there if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast you'll see it above my left
shoulder here otherwise i'm just going
to describe it here real quick so this
is a junk drawer i use
drawer dividers from a company called
salt i don't know that i would recommend
them because there's a lot of waste in
their packaging when i ordered it now
they're custom junk drawer dividers
there's not a whole lot of junk in this
junk drawer though it's everything that
is useful for me so it's rather
intentional but i will say that
everything in this drawer i think
everything in the drawer
might be a duplicate of something that
is elsewhere in the house so you can see
i have a toothbrush and toothpaste like
and this is our kitchen why do you have
a toothbrush in the kitchen just in case
man yeah right no not really
i because i don't want to wake my wife
up in the morning i get up way before
her and so i don't want to like run the
water while she's still sleeping and
wake her up so i just go out to the
kitchen and i brush my teeth out there
that's so sweet isn't it that's what i'm
so swissy again these are the kind of
couples i want to model myself after
uh i can't make fun of you dude my ocd
kicked out i'm borderline turned on
looking at that i was like that is
exactly
how you organize a drawer
sir that looks great no i will tell you
everything in here so you got some gum
you have a little massage tool that i
use
on like my calves i use that regularly
some floss in there there's one of those
little balls you put underneath your
feet when you're sitting at a desk and
you just massage the bottoms of your
feet
there's a few guitar picks in there
which i use regularly i have a red pen
and a black pen i have a tape measure
which is a duplicate i have a tape
measure in our in our toolbox i never
want to go like take i use a tape
measure all the time don't ask why um
and i need access to it so i'm like why
don't i just make one that's easily
accessible so maybe this isn't very
minimalist to me because most of the
things in here are duplicate items but
these are things that i use with
regularity and also this is my junk
drawer my wife has a separate maybe not
as tidy but relatively tidy junk drawer
as well although her junk drawer is
twice the size and so i get to store a
few things in there occasionally too um
i don't have a junk drawer yet but i
want to use this time to
mention something about social media
when you talked about your living room
and you know not always being perfect or
whatever yesterday i noticed that my
social media my instagram stories at the
jamie killstein it was like me at the
beach me at a fancy restaurant oh look
i'm at a fancy hotel for the first time
all this stuff
and
i also realized that earlier in that day
i had a panic attack i had complete
imposter syndrome about do i deserve
this life i have i've been
catastrophizing all this stuff and so i
made a post about that and i tweeted
that too and i go hey
i'm catching myself doing the the thing
the the thing we criticize influencers
about like you know when you see like a
couple and they did some kind of like
photo shoot and the the first line in it
is just like babe we've been through a
lot and you're like oh they are
struggling right now um i was doing that
i was doing that
and
and part of me was probably posting that
cool stuff because i was feeling down on
myself and i was like no but look i'm at
the beach i can't feel sad and so yeah i
posted that just to be like hey guys
just so you know like
my life looks really dope right now and
it is and i'm very grateful for it and
yesterday was pretty much like 80 an
awesome day um but also i had these
struggles and dude the amount of people
who started hitting me back and they're
like thank you for posting that like i'm
trying to teach my kids this i'm trying
to you know all this stuff so the
internet is not real all the time social
media is definitely not real all the
time so feel free to roast me in the
comments if you want to make fun of my
ocd in the junk drawer or wrong if they
do and uh what i will say is that future
episodes as we're going through these
photo friday home tours that we post
every friday for our video patreon
subscribers you can see photos of inside
our homes and we'll now the tk's moving
and we'll get into ryan's home as well
you're going to see some imperfections
it's not going to look like it's a part
of real simple magazine there'll be
times where even this you wouldn't put
in real simple magazine but
i don't like to hide clutter in drawers
i'm going to put something in a drawer i
want it to still have a purpose i don't
want to stack things up i don't want to
hide
my clutter i don't want to hide a bunch
of dead things in these drawers
yeah i love the contrast that you're
showing the immaculate version where
it's tidy organized and neat but you're
also willing to show hey here's what it
looked like before so that people can
kind of get the inspiration that comes
from that before and after that a lot of
this pristine organized minimalistic
simple look
doesn't just come from you being gifted
by the gods or you just having it easy
or whatever it may be like no you too
know what it's like to have to make
decisions about clutter or have to adapt
to a new space this is all useful junk
for me as soon as something ceases to be
useful
then it's real junk this is an actual
junk for me right these are
non-essentials that add value to my life
and i will retain them as long as i
continue to get value from them and they
don't get in the way
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
patreon.com slash the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100
advertisement free